did you know that Netflix has released
and will release plenty of animated
series that are actually based on
popular movies stay tuned to find out
more about a series that actually
started with the world's most famous
popular 60s toys if you're new here make
sure to subscribe to the things and give
our video a big thumbs up now let's
check out 10 animated series on Netflix
based on your favorite movies all hell
King Julien let's start with a movie
that's one of our favorite guilty
pleasures even though Madagascar is a
movie for kids we can't help but love
its witty humor and its hilarious
characters but what's even better is
seeing those characters and plenty of
new scenarios and that's all thanks to
all hail King Julien which focuses on of
course King Julien and plenty of other
Madagascar characters even though the
series wrapped up in 2017 and produced
its final season you can still watch the
entire thing on Netflix and trust us if
you love the Madagascar franchise you'll
absolutely love all hail King Julien who
would have thought
Madagascar would continue to be so
popular Dragons race to the edge ever
heard of dragons raced to the edge if it
sounds familiar it's because it's
connected to How to Train Your Dragon
which is pretty much everyone's favorite
animated movie even though the show
ended in 2017 it had raving reviews of
everyone that loves How to Train Your
Dragon and the best part about the
series apart from the fact that it's on
Netflix is that it's for both kids and
adults if you're planning on watching it
just make sure you give the first season
a pass as fans have noticed that things
get much more exciting from the second
season a perfect series for those who
have always wondered how youths of How
to Train Your Dragon and grew up spirit
riding free everyone knows that one kid
that's completely obsessed with horses
do you remember in 2002 a movie called
spirit stallion of the Cimarron it got
an Oscar nomination so it definitely
deserves your attention well that same
movie has been made into two animated
series that pass its third season in
2017 and is still ongoing as of February
2018 the series is set in a town of Mara
Darrow
in Oregon and it focuses on Lucky's
attempts to fit in and find friends it's
definitely something both kids and
adults can relate to although the show
might be a bit boring for adults it's
definitely entertaining for children
sylvania okay Castlevania might not be
directly based on your favorite movie
but we all know what started every
single Dracula movie ever
it's the 1897 horror book and the 1992
movie Dracula that's still one of the
most popular horror movies ever
Castlevania is all about Dracula's and
demons this series is still running
strong as of February 2018 and it's
definitely a must watch if you love
anything related to Dracula it's full of
action and it even features a demon
hunter a magician and a half vampire son
Castlevania has amazing reviews but it's
definitely not a show you'd watch with
your kids unless you want them to have
nightmares for the next few weeks
troll hunters now this is the series
we're all ready for trollhunters was a
successful 2010 movie but its popularity
doesn't seem to want to end the animated
series which released its first season
in 2016 will be wrapping up in 2018 when
it will release its third and also final
season the fans are completely ecstatic
they'll be able to explore the story of
two royal teenage aliens and their
bodyguard the very final chapter of
season 3 will air in 2019 so you better
stay tuned because 2018 is going out to
be one of the most exciting years yet
for animated series you bet we'll be
watching trollhunters Kiera let's talk
about some more shows that are scheduled
to make a comeback in 2018 and Beyond
eighties kids probably remember the girl
power icon Shira but what he might not
know is that she's coming back Shira was
created after the demands for a female
lead fantasy series grew and since that
demand is still ongoing it makes sense
to probably bring it back it's produced
by an award-winning author and executive
producer noelle stevenson so you already
know it'll be amazing this version of
Shira is all about female friendships
and empowerment of course having a
warrior princess as the lead character
makes it that much better to the boss
baby back in business
speaking of surprisingly good movies and
2017 boss baby got animated for an Oscar
it's hard to believe that a charming
movie about a baby spy would be so
popular and so critically acclaimed it
would actually get nominated for an
Oscar but the popularity of the boss
baby and his gang continues with the
boss baby back in business series the
series still focuses on boss baby Tim
they
the core and the rest of the game as of
February 2018 the official release date
hasn't yet been announced however you
will be able to see if the
oscar-nominated boss may be on screen
again and 2018 Harvey Street kids
does the name sound familiar Harvey
Street was a 1941 comic book that was
the birthplace of plenty of lovable
characters Richie Rich Casper the
Friendly Ghost Felix the Cat and more
were all featured in the Harvey Street
comic book many of those characters also
later appeared in movies but this time
it's all about the three Harvey Street
girls the series will be available on
Netflix in 2018 and we have no doubt
that it will also feature some of the
old Harvey Street characters that have
already starred in some of our favorite
movies who doesn't love a good series
full of nostalgia fingers crossed
Netflix does this one writes the epic
tales of Captain Underpants speaking of
stories that just last and last
Captain Underpants completely took over
the world the book was a huge success
among the younger crowd so much so that
the franchise also released its first
movie in 2017 but this story is not over
yet
DreamWorks announced will be getting the
Captain Underpants series as of February
2018
the date hasn't yet been confirmed but
all we do know is that this show will
air sometime in 2018 and we're pretty
sure this one is one of those were most
excited about how can you not love
George beard and Harold Hutchins and
their adventures we can't wait for this
one trolls the beat goes on who would
have ever thought that a toy from the
60s would still be popular today troll
dolls not only adapted to the modern
times but they also started a pretty
interesting craze but stay tuned because
if you love trolls you'll be excited
about this announcement in 2016 trolls
the movie was created and in 2017
DreamWorks announced trolls the beef
goes on TV series in case you're
wondering this series came out on the
19th of January in 2018 and we're all
pretty excited about it even though it
might not be for adults which show will
you be watching on Netflix let us know
in the comments that's it for our video
don't forget to subscribe to the things
and hit that like button for more videos
like this one see you next time
[Music]